hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
einen tick tock account auf dem ich
qualitativ hochwertige videos hochladen
davon war nichts fake lasten daumen hoch
auf jeden fall versteht optik doch
leider nicht jeder meinen humor meine
geistreichen messages hinter den sektor
videos von daher reagieren wir heute auf
einige kommentare die so unter meine tik
tok videos geschrieben werden hast du
der behinderung ja alle
jede behinderung die es gibt luca
gleichwohl schwul schwul schwul schwul
schwul schwul schwul schwul schwul
also laut dem user hd ich bin der boss
interessanter name laut ihm bin ich also
13 mal schwul
das ist sehr interessant schlecht der
tik tok user der zu beginn diesen
kommentar von wegen hat seine
behinderung geschrieben hat ist der
gleiche user der gerade schlecht
geschrieben hat also lieber markhardt
laurin anscheinend hast du ein
generelles problem mit mir
alleskleber genau genau du lauf
und wie lange man lustig wie kacke
ich finde das total lustig eine mutter
ist black
ich weiß gar nicht was ich so was
antworten soll so schlecht stehen hier
[Musik]
für jedes big talk video hat sich
irgendwie daraus dass entwickler video
dauert zehn minuten natürlich ist das
schlecht eine ausgeburt der hölle
erreicht die erde bei dem kommentar
musste ich will talk night schmunzeln da
kann so ein kleines kichern über war kam
ich da die macht man diesen strich in
der mitte dieser kommentar wurde unter
einen tick tock video von mir gepostet
wo ich eine grimasse gemacht habe
und da du mich gefragt hast wie ist
diesem strich in der mitte gemacht habe
das ist ein ziemlich teurer
videoeffekten habe ich den after effects
gemacht das nennt sich die gülle ich
kenne dich als kontrast und möchte so
gerne dass du mein freund bist
wahnsinnig ich bin nie pünktlich du
kannst dich nie auf mich verlassen du
kannst nie ein geburtstagsgeschenk von
mir weil ich den immer vergessen werde
und ich bin auch einfach so ein
kompletter voll spaß also keine ahnung
warum wir mit mir befreundet sein will
klapphandy ist klar dass du die app
selbst benutzt
ja natürlich ist mir klar dass ich die
benutzen wenn ich dadurch selber videos
hochladen und kein einziges mal
getroffen der kommentar wurde untermain
gestern hochgeladenes video gepostet wo
ich ja diese einzigartigen tricks
gemacht habe und mein lieber stars
unterstrich m12 1 21 es tut mir sehr
sehr leid dass du erkannt hat dass ich
kein einziges mal getroffen hat so das
war definitiv nicht der sinn der sache
omg du musst zum friseur ja ich weiß
ich will meine haare agieren so ein
bisschen länger wachsen lassen aber
jetzt gerade sehen sie hat einfach nur
scheiße aus manchmal ins passt zum rest
von mir jeder youtuber macht sich über
tik tok lustig aber macht es dann selbst
alter facetime und sonnen männliches
symbol
ok naja also realtech ich mache mich
auch oft über youtuber lustig und macht
selber auch youtube videos
ich mache mich auch über mich selbst auf
lustig ich kann mich auch artig doch
lustig machen aber selbst die top videos
machen verstehe nicht was dein problem
ist oft gibt es einfach echt unfassbar
viele queens leute die übliche sachen
hochladen
die hochgeladenen ihren los über sowas
macht man sich nicht lustig problem mit
bart hast du ja zum glück nicht noch
steht ich verstehe nicht dass alle haben
ich habe halt ich habe wirklich kein
bart du hattest nicht mehr titel wozu
dieser schmerz dieser kommentar wurde
unter das tik tok video von mir gepostet
in dem ich das erste mal eine black mask
ausprobiert habe ich mache jetzt auch
mal so einen blick ich brauche es jetzt
mein gesicht 24 stunden später richtig
scheiße jetzt mal ab wie neu und wird
auch egal ob mein pickel hat oder nicht
eine black mask tut einfach nur hellweg
black wieder plastik in einer pizza
jetzt hast es mir aber gegeben ja sollte
wenn du kann sich für seine fans
interessieren würde würde er eine
bessere firma neben der kommentar wurde
ebenfalls unter das black neues video
geschrieben und zwar bemängelt diese
personen dass ich eine beschissene black
mask firma marke whatever genommen habe
ganz kurze info für dich ich habe
einfach das erste produkt bestellt was
bei google kam und das habe ich dann für
das siegtor video benutzt das video war
nicht sponsored und ich würde auch nicht
werbung für diese marke machen keine
ahnung ob die gute oder schlechte sachen
raus bringen meine bleckmann es war auf
jeden fall heftig beschissen aber wenn
du wirklich meint dass der kauf einer
black mails die die nicht deinen
ansprüchen entspricht nun bedeutet dass
ich mich für meine fans interessieren
dann bis zu echten kompletter affen boss
ich habe eine die lässt man nur 15
minuten einwirken die tut gar nicht weh
wer lässt die den 24 stunden drauf
stimmt alter wäre es seine maske 24
stunden drauf 24 stunden später die
chance jetzt mal ab langweiligste tik
tok
das ist dass geht mir jetzt wirklich ins
herz der weint mein herz hoffentlich
bist du gestorben
ja ich eigentlich bin ich tot unlustig
soll er auch nie lustig sein
ich will euch einfach um einen skill
präsentieren als maulburg gehört ja
einfach seine eigenen tik tok tok mal
ganz kurz was ist daran so schlimm ich
mein ich lag auf meine youtube videos
selbst weil ich da einfach stundenlang
saß und mit dem mit gesamtkonzept
zufrieden bin und wenn ich mit etwas
zufrieden bin und das cool findet der
lack ist so wie ich auch einen tick der
video kindersitz nicht gleich zu zehn
minuten dran aber auch wenn ich das cool
findet dann likes auch wenn es mein
eigenes ist auch scheißegal habe ich
einen like mehr luca mit grauen haaren
wer einfach schon mendes leute ich habe
einen tipp für dich brille fielmann ist
dass der witz dumme fratzen und brille
mein lieber morys der einzige witz hier
bist du ganz kurzer einschub ebenem ich
befinde mich gerade im schnitt des
videos und ich möchte nicht dass es
bisher so rübergekommen ist oder
irgendjemanden so rüber gekommen sein
sollte tun das habe ich möchte nicht
dass sie das video hier in so eine
richtung geht ich gegen die leute auf
tik tok oder beziehen wir irgendwelche
hacker oder kommentarschreiber 99
prozent der kommentare die ich euch
bisher gezeigt habe und auf die ich
bisher reagiert habe hat 06 also es ist
jetzt nicht so dass da jeder am helden
ist so die community optik ist
eigentlich sehr sehr sehr sehr
freundlich und freundlicher als auf
vielen anderen social media plattformen
einmal so soll überhaupt nicht so rüber
kommen als würde ich die plattform
hätten oder irgendwie leute die auf
kommentare schreiben oder als wäre wäre
ich kritik und fähig aber nun habe
steuerte kommentare rausgesucht wollte
auch diese kommentare reagieren und
das mache ich jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen und ich möchte nicht dass es
irgendwie so rüberkommt von wegen
beleidigung
wieso wird mir so ein hu so
vorgeschlagen meine mutter ist keine
[ __ ]
aber du wirst jetzt gemeldet und
blockiert ist er nicht dieser youtuber
luca der ist ja komplett
geil und du hast plastik in apples
schreibst du sowas unter ein kicktor
video von mir bei der luca pizza 42
pizzen mit einem produktionsfehler
leider mit ein wenig plastik darauf die
wurden alle zurückgerufen keiner wurde
verletzt und haben uns die zahlreich
entschuldigt mehr können wir da auch
nicht machen und produktionsfehler
passieren in deutschland tausende am tag
aber ich weiß was willst du mir damit
jetzt sagen du bist schwul man diese
ganzen leute die schwul als beleidigung
nutzen
es ist fucking 2009 10 kommt klar dass
eine probeversion bei der kommentiert
und da mein ticket das zum fig ist eine
slow mo gruppe schreibt man da ganz
langsam und wartet vier tage auf eine
antwort oder war es eher ab lärm licht
ja ich weiß mein schreibtisch haben wir
hatten früher ein mädchen in unserer
klasse ihr lieblingsessen war otto und
sie ließ juli ja dass meine freundin
wenn man versucht lustig zu sein und die
ganzen 13 jährigen ist unglaublich
witzig finden hh clinton
ich könnte jetzt ganz lange
argumentieren aber es reicht einfach nur
zu sagen dass der name himmel schwitz
ist welche person ist jetzt krieg ich
dachte mein krebs im endstadium ist
schon schlimm
real torge einerseits ist es natürlich
eine krasse beleidigungen hier gegenüber
aber andererseits falls du wirklich
krebs haben solltest wünsche ich dir gut
besserung und hat
nur so gesagt haben solltest dann bist
du sehr sehr sehr sehr schlechter mensch
wer will in dieses logo gruppe warst du
fähig ist das logo gruppe wie grobe
stich mit einem muttermal ist so alter
voll komisch wenn menschen muttermal hat
das schlechteste was ich das jetzt
gesehen habe
sorry aber ich kann deine tik tok nicht
ernst nehmen sollte man noch nicht und
das ist gerade der sinn der ganzen sache
meine lieben freunde also die ich mach
tik tok wirklich nicht um irgendwie
anderen zu zeigen hey guck mal wie gar
nicht bearbeiten kann oder hey guck mal
wie schön ich bin oder was auch immer
ja ich will mich einfach über mich
selbst lustig machen
und wer das versteht und wer das cool
findet kann mir gerne folgen ich als der
laser luca aber wer das nicht versteht
ja beleidigt mich gern weiter in den
kommentaren an der stelle ich mich jetzt
allerdings auch beende meine lieben
freunde mit euch gefallen hat dann das
gern mal einen daumen hoch bei diesem
video das scheint mir gerne euren krieg
dort nahmen und in die kommentare dann
schicke ich auf jeden fall einige
profile von euch aus und abonniert gerne
meinen kanal
[Musik]